[Music]
dad look in your eyes I recognize it
survivors just like I nah that is my
name exiles ina ina fray
which means lone fighter for a long time
I've searched for worthy companion a
hunter as peers and strong and has
simmers ina I walk the plains of vaster
II and found no one worthy I delved into
the azurite mines even though my best
friend Nico begged me not to I found
many crunchy bugs but still no hunter
then I decided there was only one place
left to search the land
oh this is not the menagerie ina must
have taken a wrong turn on the path of
Exile I make joke haha you like it I
know where I am
do you do you do you I know because I na
nose
welcome to exile called 2019 for Oh as
the local survivors like to say Keanu
from the land of the orc yes now what
was I going to say hmm I have come oh
yes we have people here from all over
the planet yes yes very brave to come
here all this way but don't worry here
we have a Tech's alcohol shelter food
and weapons I hope you bring your
weapons
ah
I brought mine come come shadow come
come
this is my shadow he goes everywhere
with me
now do we have any peace in the building
oh this one I said do we have any beasts
in the building
oh yes I hear you well now I know I can
hear well my beasts friends you know
what I like to do with a beast I like to
hunt them and kill them with my bare
claws well they're not really bear claws
but you know if I can't kill them with
my bare claws you know I like to use my
crossbow I prefer to call it my happy
board ha ha ha ha
you see come son come this is how it
works
when I'm hunting first of all if I'm
going for a big beast like this one here
he looks like a big beast stand up beast
not you the big one next to you you you
are too skinny you will make a good
carcass yeah very useful don't worry we
use all the pieces of the animal like
grinding gears using all the pieces for
the game big beasts stand up what is
your name what no she okay welcome no
she put your hands up so I can aim
straight no no put your hands up but did
I say put them down I tell you when to
put your hands down
so when I'm hunting a baby please like
no she I have to tread very carefully
I'm stalking now I'm not talking
I am stalking and then I taking aim
generally in oh she's dimension and boom
he's capture you can sit down now when
I'm going for a slightly smaller beast I
have to yes you can stand up now small
yes what is your name very exotic name
so when I'm aiming for smaller bees like
what Jason okay when I'm going to take a
shot Jason here I have to aim more
carefully like these
and lining up my shot and boom he's been
captured good yeah I know it's very good
shadow where are you you can take it
away because when I'm hunting little
tiny insects I can't use my crossbow can
I so I have to stamp on them it's funny
oh yes funny so if I'm if I'm standing
on there I have to stand for few times
because one little insect is not very
nutritious is it so I have lots of
insect I picked them up I eat them very
nutritious very good so today I have
come from very far away to be here the
exact oh yes do you know how many bees I
had to sacrifice to get here today just
to get the portal open
I lost count at 50 Beast and I will have
to sacrifice 50 more just to get back to
my menagerie but don't worry because
here today you where we are here or we
came all of us here to celebrate all of
us here to celebrate you are going to
get a chance to meet the originals they
all the first ones from grinding Gear
games don't worry they are not going to
bite you like the first ones I knives
used to don't worry they are very
friendly beasts you're going to get to
talk to them and they are going to talk
to you it's going to be great today
at this convention is here for ina to
meet all his friends and talk about all
his achievements
but this is not I Nicole this is exile
car
now now if this was ina corn things
would be very different the main event
would be sacrificed by combat yes I'm
coming to you you - yes - lucky
survivors here are you married oh then
this should be very easy for you because
when you are married you will find a lot
of fighting going on lot of sin and you
know it very very easy but so don't
worry things are only gonna get worse
now sacrifice by combat
I like that if this was obviously we
also I have to say out there on one of
the stages we have streamers do you know
what streamers is yeah if this was ina
corn we would just have lots of blood
and goo and snot and everything just
pouring off the stage all over you
married people you like that huh we can
see who has the biggest blood stream it
will be good oh I like your hair it's
very nice Beast the only problem is he
can't see behind you now you can see I
like it you have to tell me what you're
doing with your hair so we are going to
have streamers this is not really what
it is
streamers is where you have another
stage out there and you will be able to
talk and speak talk and need more meat
more talk more meat more talk
me I am hungry I didn't have my
breakfast this morning meat no this is
what it is streamers now the other thing
you will be able to do today in exile
calm you will be able to buy many many
things many many things you lucky people
that is exclusive here to exile cool
let me show Oh No save it this one is
very rare this is an Aldi Nora
very rare here is a little beast here
it's a baby rower very cute yes no it
grows into a huge monster will eat you
up hahahaha this one is for you
somewhere that he's captured he's
captured here we have another beast this
is a court the Sandra's ancestor and
Santos a spitter I think they call it
yeah sensible I think I used to date one
no I think I you I think I used to age
one yeah that's it haha I not make funny
funny haha
this one's for you oh yeah and this one
here for you too because you're lovers I
like you give it to them
and one over here oh very good catching
but this is my baby
this is very rare it's a little a Dino
for my new friend down here so today we
are going to have there are
announcements to be made
you have to listen out because I have
been told by the first ones they are
going to be announcements they are going
to be games you can play so you have to
listen and I know has been told to say
this I do not know what it means but
this is what I've been told I know I was
also told to prepare a long talk yes
this is better I think you know a long
talk is boring I know it's only used to
talking to be slimmer naturally and they
do not listen good so Andy good poetry
thank you what is your name
Thank You Russell for putting me on the
spot I love to hunt I love to smile but
most of all I love you excise
but more than that I love to hunt now
I'm going to make a special announcement
now do not do what they roar do okay do
not do your toilet all over the floor
all over the table all right
there is defecation houses just roll
into the foyer please use that the other
thing of course is if there is a fire
please make your way to the nearest safe
exit you look around you'll find your
nearest exit
make your way very carefully very
quietly and if you do want to light a
fire now I think this is all I have to
say so without any further ado I'm going
to introduce you now to three of my best
friends they are more beautiful and they
smell better than the beasts in the
menagerie except on patch days
they are seasoned ina exists we wouldn't
be here without them please put your
claws together for the three founding
fathers of grinding Gear games path of
Exile please welcome Chris Jonathan and
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
love you too
hi everyone I'm Chris Wilson from
grinding Gear games and welcome to exile
con this is Erica creative director and
of course
[Applause]
he's responsible for all of the scary
[ __ ] that you've seen and are gonna see
and this is Jonathan our technical
director how are you feeling everyone
it's it's pretty scary up here honestly
you know how people in the audience ton
of people online it's yes six - just
watching on Twitch
yes everywhere else and there's a lot of
people out there well it's honestly
really amazing that all you guys could
join us here in New Zealand we
understand it's really far away from
everywhere else in the world I think
like a 12 hour flight to anywhere except
for Australia hopefully more than a few
of you are doing really fun activities
in New Zealand like visiting Hobbiton
and that's really good worth checking
out
so we've been preparing the content
you're gonna see this weekend for a
really long time many years and after so
many years of planning it's finally it's
amazing to finally be here on stage to
present it thank you so much for coming
to see it in person and thanks to
everyone who tuned in from home to watch
the livestream so when we released path
of exile 1.0 back in 2013 we had around
20 developers at grinding Gear games
they fit in one room that version of the
game only went up to act 3 it was
primitive by today's standards and was
the first version of path of Exile that
we were proud enough to call fully
released we knew that to keep the game
from getting stale we had to do
something really big every couple of
years in addition to the regular free
content expansions so by 2015 our studio
had around 45 developers moved into its
current office and this allowed us to
create an entirely new act of content
for version 2.0 extending the length of
path of Exile storyline by a third while
2.0 was a big expansion we knew the jump
to hit 3.0 had to be a lot bigger so we
expanded the studio to 90 developers and
were able to add six new acts of content
in 2017 that was honestly one of the
best moments of my life after keeping
the secret that we're adding six new
acts
there weren't any leaks we released a
trailer that kept revealing new acts in
sequence and the reactions from the
community were amazing it just made all
the hard work worthwhile so since then
we've been asking ourselves the question
how are we possibly going to top that
well over the last two years we've
expanded up to 145 developers and we're
really proud to finally reveal path of
Excel 4.0
[Music]
the gods are dead but left on their own
men will always seek to take their place
criminals your sentence is to be hanged
from the neck until dead
let your souls be the first ones and
your bodies need the land the only
result is pain and death
still
only 20 years since kotappa felt and
already corruption spreads like a plague
to the shattered lands wretched
it is our
it must be done
every class
[Music]
[Applause]
well that feels amazing thank you Hut
the Vics alto is an Oriole I'm set 20
years after the defeat of Kotova when we
finished developing 3.0 we knew that we
couldn't extend part of excels campaign
forever adding more acts will make the
game just too long before players got to
maps at the same time we knew we really
needed to bring the quality of paths of
excels campaign up to a 2019 standard we
realized that we needed to make a new
campaign four years now we've been
wanting to make a sequel to path of
excel the problem with that though is
that sequels split a community between
two products it's also hard for a sequel
to compete with the amount of content
and features that the original game has
we've just spent six years making
expansions for part of Excel so imagine
if we released a path of Excel - and it
was just a bear campaign with none of
that extra content this would be a sad
shell of an action RPG compared to the
current set of paths of Excel it has
none of the years of expansion content
and improvements that make the game
great so we're creating path of Exile -
as a new campaign alongside path of XR 1
with a shared endgame the original
campaign is still fully playable and
because it's the same game it'll still
continue to be maintained with all the
updates and game system improvements
that will make two paths of excel when
we add new skills to the game you'll be
able to play with them in either the
path of XL 1 or path of Excel to
campaign and all the microtransactions
and stash tabs are your purchased in the
past will be fully usable regardless of
which campaign you're playing
most importantly all of your favorite
path of exile expansion content like
delve breach incursion and lesion will
be fully integrated at the same time we
wanted the freedom to make all of the
changes that a true sequel requires like
changing the skill system all of the
ascendency classes improving the engine
and a lot of other things that we aren't
announcing this weekend path of excel to
addresses all of the things that we feel
at deficiencies in path of excel one
we're not abandoning the path of excel
one campaign though not only is it still
fully supported in path of excel 4.0
we're doing a lot of work to get it up
to a 2019 standard here's what x1 town
looks like in 3.9 which we're releasing
in four weeks
we're also going through the campaign
and we're improving materials to work
with our new physically based rendering
pipeline over the next year you're going
to see a lot of improvements to the path
of excel one campaign which will be
deployed ahead of 400 with a 3.9 series
of patches wall sorry rigging all the
old character classes to work with the
new 4.0 animations so you'll get all of
the ongoing animation improvements and
the old path of xr1 campaign as well in
the next year we're going to continue to
deliver four amazing leaks on a regular
three-month cycle all of this content is
designed with the path of excel to
campaign in mind and will continue to
fold it into the game as needed like we
would with any other league we don't
have a firm release date for path of X
or 2 yet and are absolutely going to
wait until it's ready before releasing
it we're planning on waiting at least
another year with 3.9 expansions before
the beta of 4.0 though so I'm sure
you're wanting to see some 4.0 gameplay
we've prepared a live demo for you
everything ready Jonathan alright let's
go
today Jonathan's going to do a short
live demo of some of the content we have
in this build of path of Excel to this
is played right live like he's literally
playing right there we're starting here
at about level 11 which is about halfway
through
act 1 and because we want everyone
seeing the playable demo of the show on
the show floor to be able to experience
the start of act 1 without having any
other surprises spoil for you so right
away as Jonathan plays through the
graveyard you'll notice the massive
improvements we've made to the path of
Exile engine since 3.0 was released
environments characters and items all
used physically based rendering which
gives the whole game a realistic look we
have new main character classes new main
character class bottles with all new
animations and completely new item base
types most of these have physics for
many of the little details which look a
lot of a lot more awesome than before
[Music]
we've put a lot of work into updating
skill effects for example when you fire
a split arrow you really feel the
individual errors because they can stick
in objects and they can bounce off
others realistically
[Applause]
[Music]
this looks so good
slight spoiler but that support Jamie's
using turns any skill into a Faraj Eddie
Bosco so the 4.0 campaign contains a
variety of optional side-quests that
lead to meaningful boss encounters
relatively soon out Jonathan's going to
encounter an NBC called Lachlan who has
lost his family and needs help Isabel
and the boys were ready to be gone for a
few minutes but it is Benin they don't
even know how long hours at least days
weeks what season is it stranger I know
we have just met but I'm so worried
about them around here they could have
fallen into a sinkhole or being choked
by grave dust please could you see to
their safety
[Music]
the game has changed a lot more than
just a visually though one of the things
we've really wanted to do for a long
time is to make fundamental changes to
path of Excel skill system the school
system in Peoria is really cool and
versatile personally it's one of my
favorite things about the game but there
have always been some awkward things
about it we really wanted to find a way
to address all of the shortcomings while
not sacrificing even a single bit of the
functionality that we already have so
you can see in the inventory here
there's something missing all of the
sockets on the items this is because in
path of Excel to you no longer put gems
into your items instead the skill gems
themselves have sockets as you can see
here and there is a dedicated screen for
socketing them Johnathan's going to
change a split arrow skill for a shot
and add some support gems to it there is
some really big advantages here for one
every single skill gems path of exile 2
can be a six-link this is going to cause
huge changes and help players design
character builds in the past players
didn't want to have more than one
primary attack skill because you can
only have one or two 6 links on your
character now it's totally viable to
have a lot of powerful primary attack
skills with full support gems the thing
I'm really happy about though is you
don't have to screw around with your
gems all the time when you're leveling
check out this bow here the socket
colors are the same between the two bows
they're both 4 green sockets like every
other bow in the game and this means
that when you find it you item you just
slap it on you don't have to think about
getting fuses and rollers out because
you do that on the gems themselves as we
swap between the bows as well
[Applause]
and for clarity this means that endgame
when you're trying to roll your perfect
item you can focus on the mods and
separately on the sockets and the skills
so you'll see here as jonathan swaps
turbos the DPS values for all your
skills updated a glance and that's
because we've completely breached
changed how the character screen works
and so on Jonathan will go into more
detail later today about that so it's
still possible to fine-tune socket
colors on items if you need to but
because everything that drops has fixed
sockets it's way easier to just pick
something up and put it on while you're
leveling for new players and other
really great advantages there's now
impossible to socket a support gem into
a skill gem it doesn't work with for
example multiple projectiles here just
can't go into leap slam but as you can
see it works on the other bow skills so
you might be wondering about skills like
auras a lot of the time in the old skill
system you would throw a few gems
together in a four-link with few or no
support gems how can you do that when
you have such a limited number of active
skill slots now the answer is meta gems
meta gems are like super support gems
that let you put multiple actives into
them for example we want to run a few
different auras on this character so we
put the proficiency gem into the
character and loaded up full of auras
it even gives you a single keybinds you
could use to cuss all of yours with one
click
[Applause]
trigger gems like cast on crater also
made a gem so this means you can put an
entire cast on crits set up in one gem
as one of your eight-six links you can
now have there is a huge amount more to
talk about with what meta gems allow you
to do with path of excel skill system
and Jonathan will be going into all of
it in the pier we get pob - gameplay
deep dive later today he'll cover how
all the existing path of Excel things
work and path of Exile - as well as
introducing a whole lot of new stuff
that is our talk and not to miss oh and
I should add the supports you're seeing
here for the bow skills there 3 point 9
content so you'll get to see that much
much sooner and that's something I want
to emphasize while path of Excel 4.0
sorry path of exile 2 is we're now
calling the campaign is still fight our
way we are getting as much of the
content in as early as we can apart from
the campaign itself so you'll get to
play most of the new stuff we're doing
quite a lot earlier it's the campaign in
the skill system that are being rolled
up on launch day so one of the things we
really wanted to improve on path of
exile 2 was our lighting system the new
PBR rendering in addition to a much more
realistic light fall-off makes this area
look significantly better than we could
possibly achieve in the past
[Music]
so you can see here there are some
monsters called courtesans who can
explode the blood presence when blood
prisons are covered in blood they get a
lot stronger so you have to be careful
we've tried very hard to design very
interesting monster fights starting as
early as Act one of the new campaign
[Music]
area generated much longer than usual we
did it every other day what we do yeah
but that's actually a feature that I'm
with we're proud of we have put a lot of
work and to make sure there's even more
randomization on our random areas I know
racers will hate to hear that because
they can't memorize the layouts but we
want it
be very very hard to find your way
around and there's a talk that Reese is
doing later
I think it's tomorrow morning where
we're talking about topics like world
generation and stuff like that rather
than just level generation you'll you'll
see what he has to say but it's pretty
pretty interesting happen on the stage
River we have to give you an authentic
part of Excel experience involving some
backtracking I've got a quick syllabus
over all right here we go this
run-through is going a lot better than
some of the rehearsals we did it turns
out some of the monsters hit pretty hard
if you're not good at this
what's that sir yeah you gotta level
your gems up column ah
so this is exile calm place Keeley okay
should we go left or right
awesome
[Music]
[Applause]
Goody's make them stop then we strain
the screaming no don't give it
so one of the things that's really
exciting about creating an entirely new
campaign is that we get to apply all of
our boss creation skills to early bosses
as well the first few acts of the
original path of Excel have bosses that
are some of the earliest content we ever
made and their age is really showing for
comparison this fight here is that the
same level as fair graves in the
original campaign but as you can see
it's a lot more advanced with a lot more
going on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
a new level of animation
[Music]
so here we are a nine house favorite
place the hunting grounds now we're
ready to show you something that players
have been requesting for a really long
time you've seen it in Popovic salto we
finally have shape-shifting so each
shape ship form can use any regular path
of Excel to attack that makes sense
here on the werewolf for example we're
using leap slam and cleave and one of
the things that we thought was really
important with shape-shifting is that
you can change back and forth at
literally any time mid animation walking
around in the middle of a skill whatever
just hit the button and change forms
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so one of the things that we're really
proud of is a new grass technology we
have it's done using precomputed ray
tracing and is way nicer looking and as
a much better performance than what we
used before got some friends there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so that right there is a small slice of
path of excel - thank you very much
thank you very much Jonathan so almost
the entirety of ax1 path of exile - is
complete and playable today on the show
floor it's not just those areas it
starts right on the riverbanks at the
beginning like you saw in the trailer
play all the way through that summer in
the middle if you can make it in the
45-minute time and just keep playing see
if you can get to the ex-boss that isn't
done yet we'll see please check it out
and let us know what you think you can
play it on the bottom floor of the
Convention on the top floor on one of
the 120 omen gaming pcs generously
provided by HP so logo so as I said the
demo on the show for is played right
from the side of x1 it has quite a lot
of different content than what you just
watch if you're watching from home the
best way to see this demo because you
can't buy it unfortunately is to watch
one of the streamers who's going to be
playing the demo throughout the weekend
the first of these is at noon in New
Zealand time in 19 minutes when
kripparian plays while chatting with
Jonathan
so some systems and path of exile 2 are
not ready to announce yet and so they're
not present in today's demo the first
thing a lot of you are doing is hitting
P to see the passive skill screen
surprise it's just the same as the in
development 3 901 4 now
that's because we'll work out what we're
doing at the passive skill screen blow
your socks off with that and then
announce that at some stage before
release so in around 3 and a half hours
at 2:00 p.m. Jonathan's gonna present a
deep dive into some of path of excels to
new game mechanics a closer look at the
new skill system in beta gems 19 new
ascendancy classes and more
so you definitely need to be here at
2:00 p.m. to watch that but conveniently
it's after my 1:00 p.m. deep dive about
3:00 and I know which is equally good so
just you're here for the afternoon
basically and if you're watching from
home I'm sorry if you live in Europe
right now so we've just announced how
we're making huge changes to path of
excels campaign and 4.0 how about the
endgame well it's been two years since
we launched war for the Atlas which is
our last substantial end game focused
expansion so we feel it's high time some
big changes what we'd like to show you
now is what's coming in path of Exile
3.9 which will be released in one month
listen carefully for this is important I
worked with a group of exhales once much
like yourselves
[Music]
together we face the terrible evil that
plays the athletes and threatened our
world
we were able to just be
but it wasn't enough
they kept going back
Janet again
could never be satisfied
proceed
conquer those strange land each time
they return
I feared more and more
so I did what I thought was right
i sealed them
they found a way back
[Music]
path of exile conquerors of the Atlas is
an expansion with a new endgame Atlas
storyline set after the defeat of the
elder the xl's who defeated them have
become a danger to Wraeclast Susanna has
attempted to trap them in the Atlas I
guess there's only so much grinding you
can do before you go insane
from what we can see havoc instill major
both pretty close to that point right
now so when you first open the Atlas and
three point nine it's going to look
significantly different first of all you
notice you now start on the center of
the Atlas but the much larger change is
there are only 91 maps to start with in
order to unlock the rest you're going to
need to find and defeat the conquerors
to take back watch stones and soccer
them into the Atlas socketing one of
these watch stones into a region of the
Atlas will both level up the tier of
maps and reveal new maps you can up you
can stock it up to four watch stones
into each region revealing all the maps
and eventually raising the level of the
entire Atlas so that every map is
between tier 14 and 16 if you want
[Music]
[Applause]
because you can socket a none socket
these watch stones whenever you like
you can completely customize which Maps
you're finding on the fly as your
strategy changes yup it's amazing you're
gonna find you're gonna fight for of the
conquerors many times as you play
through the new atlas these are
challenging fights so it's only fitting
that they have some special rewards if
you're lucky a conqueror might drop a
new type of support gem that we're
calling a support gem plus these new
gems are better versions of existing
supports which at level 1 are more
powerful than the level 20 versions of
the ones they replace so this has an
additional fork compared to the normal
one for example okay there's plenty more
stuff to discuss about conquerors of the
Atlas for example how do you get these
cool new currency items we'll go into
more detail about this along with the
support gem plus system the final boss
fight what's replacing shelf Schaefer
and ADA elder rares new skill and
support gems introduced in 3.9 and more
in the deep dive presentation later
today
like every other path of Exile expansion
conquerors of the Atlas also contains a
new challenge League and we have a
trailer of that League to show you take
a closer look place
repeats four times mix the five samples
and equipo medic solution heat stand
back
in terms of dollars will make itself
known
[Music]
observe its anger its aggression
deserve exchanging troll never
comfortable to stay in one shape the
wrong it will try to kill me
there's not related
punish the Cretan life four pieces
try more
more
only every living creatures ago
[Music]
in the metamorph Challenge League you
will find and collect samples from some
of the monsters you kill tani Octavius
will let you combine multiple samples of
monsters together to create a
shape-shifting metamorph whose skills
the derive from the monsters you
combined defeating the metamorph world
many rewards including new currency
items called catalysts that let you add
various types of special quality
modifiers to your jewelry these quality
modifiers both improve specific types of
mods on your jewelry and also make it
easier to craft associated mods at the
endgame multiple map bosses can be
combined to create a single highly
dangerous but rewarding metamorph I'll
be doing a deep dive into both the
Congress of the atlas expansion and the
minimal fleek that comes with it at 1
o'clock today in just over 2 hours will
of course be live-streaming this so for
a year we've had a few developers
working on a bit of an experimental
skunkworks project at the studio let's
watch a video about it
so mobile games are kind of [ __ ]
right you know peddling microphones
actions time gates energy bars random
nag screens notifications video ads you
get the idea there's really a lot of
even garbage going on a mobile games
today but in 2012 when you first release
path effects on VC you really could have
said the same thing about a lot of
free-to-play games there too so this is
what it looks like there are eight skill
binds five flasks the same gear you'd
expect to see on any part of it so again
one of the major benefits of this
project was the tech we've developed
it's allowing us to improve our tools
and engine and system across the board
for all platforms our goal is to bring
path of exile to mobile with absolutely
zero compromise we wanted to make
something that is a real path of excel
game we didn't just farm it out to an
external studio it's developed entirely
by a team here in New Zealand the only
thing that's fundamentally different
between phone games and PC games is that
you expect to play for shorter game
sessions on the phone Maps your perfect
length of the quick turnaround time
required for mobile gameplay while
retaining all of the deep systems the
path of Exile players expect
[Music]
back then we really felt like we could
do free to play on PC without a lot
player hostile stuff so we thought you
know maybe we can do the same thing on
robot maybe we can make a game that
bucks all those [ __ ] trends and make
us something that's a good game first
that just so happens to be played on the
phone
so needless to say around a year ago it
became real difficult to announce that
but we figured if we if we make a sequel
and give you that first so look the
mobile project is really experimental we
haven't really fully decided where we
want to go with it yet but we welcome
feedback and our plan is basically have
it at the show floor it's upstairs in
the chill-out zone which is secretly a
mobile zone all along and it's marked as
a chill-out zone on the map to fool you
and play the game let us know what you
think and on a personal note this isn't
script at this part so on a personal
note I was apprehensive about this
project right like I've I was I was
unsure we'd be able to do it but playing
the build this week it's good it runs
fast it plays well give it a shot
let let the actual demo do the talking
we're gonna get um Ziggy to play it with
Jo with Trevor the the mobile 4 guy
later in one of the stream sessions so
we'll see his actual legitimate
reactions and let's make it a good
product together because we all want to
be able to have something fun to do on
phones we're on the bus and stuff so
give us your feedback we'll make this
what you need it to be alright
[Applause]
so one of the great things about putting
path of Excel to iPhone and of course
Android is that we can easily create a
version that runs on Mac OS so next year
we'll be releasing path of Exile on Mac
OS alongside 3.10 3 2011 now this is
going to be the same version as a PC
version I placed on the same servers
it's the same game not segregated it's
just that you play it on your Mac so you
can play to work so I'm also pleased to
announce path of excels 3rd
collaboration with twitch prime just
before the release of conquerors of the
Atlas next month we'll be launching a
three month promotion where twitch Prime
members receive a free set of micro
transactions every month you can receive
a free one-month trial of twitch frame
of course to try it out and receive free
micro transactions and path of Exile and
other participating games so you may
have looked in your swag bag and found a
box with some cards in it at XL con we
really wanted players to interact with
our staff so we came up with a game that
has a few social elements think of it as
a card game action FEG that you could
only play at XL con so all of the GGG
staff members will be walking around
Excel con as monsters on their t-shirts
you can see their stats and then the
deck boxes you'll have weapons that
armor you can use to defeat the monsters
so when you kill them and please don't
actually kill them you'll be rewarded
with more cards as drops your character
can have equipped 1 armour 1 weapon and
a shield or a 2 hand weapon just like
the game as well as an amulet and two
rings the damage on your weapon has to
be equal to or larger than the defense
on the monster and the defense on the
armor and shield has to be equal to a
larger than the attack or the monster
your rings and amulets can count as
either attack or defense and they're
pretty rare to find this is explained on
the rules and of course ask any staff
members if you need help to attack a
monster just walk up to a staff member
wearing a shirt and show them the
equipment you want to use they'll give
you the reward and remove some of the
durability from your items so make sure
you don't waste your best items on the
trash mobs on the lower level now I
should note the staff have been told
what roles to individually use for
durability damage so if they totally
wreck one of your best items that's
because their instructions say that that
monster works your best items so it's
not their fault don't get angry at them
so what's next right you're not allowed
to attack the same monster twice in a
row so keep walking around to encounter
different staff members once you've
defeated Kotova
then you can start grinding Maps Zanna
played by her actual voice actress is
over by the map device on the middle
floor
you can buy some Maps make sure you
visit the crafting bench on the top
floor if you want to use your currency
items if you can get far enough in maps
to kill the Guardians you'll be able to
collect fragments require to challenge
the shaper of course that's me
[Music]
[Applause]
while I'm going to be super busy during
the convention I'll make time to talk to
anyone at the twitch after party who can
bring a set of fragments to challenge me
there's one other thing I wanted to
mention thanks I know who you are I I
know the account name there's one other
thing I wanted to mention while I'm here
we're hiring so if you want to work for
grinding it games and feel you have the
game development experience and skills
to make an impact on path of excel
please email us at HR at grinding Gear
comm with a cover letter resume and if
applicable code samples are in our
portfolio and the poor person that
checks that email address just got a bad
surprise okay guys so it's time to go
and explore excel con in addition to the
card game there's heaps of other things
to do you should definitely play the
gameplay demo of axe one of the path of
Exile to campaign upstairs you'll find a
chill-out zone where you can try the
experimental mobile project online at
path of Exile calm slash exile con is
your schedule that shows what talks are
happening where and what time your
favorite streamers or developers will be
hosting meet-and-greet sessions we're
appearing on the streamer stage to
answer questions and play path of exile
to tomorrow Riker will interview my
personal heroes David Brevik and Maxine
Erich Schaefer founders of Blizzard
north and creators of Diablo 1 & 2
that's going to be a session you can't
miss you'll probably also want to watch
the racing finale tomorrow to see who's
going to be crowned the Exile Con 2019
race champion winning $10,000 finally
don't forget to check out the 3 900 and
400 deep dives in two hours here in the
main theater for heaps more information
about the new expansions after all of
that we'll see you at the twitch after
party tomorrow night to relax after a
long and very busy weekend thank you so
much for attending and have a great show
[Applause]
thank you so much you know Mike I don't
know Mike there we go there we go thank
you so much guys there's a lot of fun
yeah it's so good to have you guys here
[Applause]
okay
all right
it feels like we work towards us for 13
years now yeah ma
see you around exhale con I'm the elder
by the way yeah